so same non-cons non-contest station
same yield
see the circle
and then step into this circle we're
going to step into the circle but then
i'm going to come back
and show it
i'm going to attack that thought
with my db so
it will be
a displacing
i'm not tripping him i'm not putting my
foot behind his foot and then throwing
him down
i'm going through his base through his
face here boom
but you can do it easy so beginners just
practice your fall he's just going to
practice
you can still do the yield part here
yield heart circle and then he practices
a little more advanced don't take their
leg out but enter
but you do not have to push back like
this on them you can't push into the
circle so you know over here i enter and
i push into the circle
so the yield push into the circle
and then once you get going then you
will take the leg
so a yield
take out
a yield point
he just hits boy here boy
okay so three levels of training
default to the level of skill of your uk